Hey guys!
I just got back from vacation,
and contrary to popular belief,
I'm actually NOT DEAD.
I just decided to take a little bit of break
after all my friends came into town,
and we were working like 18-hour days
for 7 days straight.
I needed to just clear my head a little bit.
But while I was away I found that
I really wanted to be back and making videos again.
And I'm sorry for the lack of videos.
I actually didn't have time to prepare
as much as I would have liked,
because this vacation was planned a while ahead
and blah blah blah.
I didn't tell you guys.
I said on Facebook and Twitter, "I'm sorry
for the lack of videos over the past five days,"
but now I'm more ready than ever
and I have got so many things
that I need to tell you about.
First off: Bob started his own YouTube channel.
He finally did it!
We've been telling him to do it for years now,
and he finally is going to be making gameplay content
and other amazing stuff for you guys.
As of right now I think he has a vlog up
announcing what's going to be on the channel,
and his first gameplay video, so check him out
in the link in the description below.
And one of the really cool things that he talks about
in his vlog is that he only really wants to
make a channel to build up a community
with which he can point in the right direction
and get to do
get them to do great things.
Which is all I've ever wanted about our community.
And the great thing is that
the bigger our community gets
the more good we can do.
Obviously, that's, you know,
not really in question,
but the problem is
that there are so many people,
it's hard to point you guys in the right direction.
And...I...I've kinda let that slip through the cracks,
because I've had plans
to make this happen for a while.
I've just haven't done anything about it.
But now that I'm back,
and now that I know that this is all happening,
now I want to dedicate myself more
to making sure that you guys
have a method by which to interact with one another
and organize for these bigger events.
So, I'm going to be making a website.
One with a simple forum system, polling and blogging,
um, and other features that you guys can
suggest in the comments below.
I want you guys to tell me what you want on the website.
But...I've had Markiplier.com reserved
for a long time now.
I just didn't know what to do with it,
and there were other things that we're planning for,
and, uh, I-I've just decided to forget all of that,
and just get this place,
Markiplier.com,
as a portal for you guys
all to rally the community together.
And I want you guys to have a place
where we can all share our ideas,
you know, we can all promote, uh,
each other's, you know,
big events that we wanna do.
We can organize charity things,
we can organize, uh, different fun times,
playing games with me, uh,
playing games with each other, you know.
Making things bigger and better
for our community as a whole,
which is just
one of the best communities on YouTube, by far.
And I'm not even saying that just to stroke your egos.
Like, you ask around, and, like, uuuh...
just checking the comments on some people's
YouTube channels and it's just...
it's animalistic, it's brutal—not all! But I mean
some of 'em are just like
they're constantly fighting
and they're constantly bickering with one another,
and I've never seen that with ours.
And I read a lot of the comments
I get posted on my videos.
And so, I know what you guys are saying,
and it really does warm my heart
that you guys have been non-stop supportive.
So I wanna make a place
where we can all channel that effort.
So thank you guys.
And that'll be up, very soon.
The other thing that I let fall through the cracks
while I was on vacation was that
I was part of another Guns of Icarus tournament.
I know you guys loved the last one,
because it was me, JesseCox, Cryaotic and Dodger,
all together on a ship against
TB and his gnarly crew of pirates.
Well, we're pirates too. But they're also—
They're bad pirates.
We're good p—
We're not good pirates, but we're pirates nonetheless.
STOP [Markiplier.exe encountered an error]
Either way,
there were supposed to be videos on my channel
announcing it, but I uploaded it before—
right before I went to vacation,
and they didn't upload.
So either way, here is some of 'em:
What is...?
[laughing]
Huh?
[Dodger noises]
Cry: Shit, I don't get it either.
Cry: I used to be pretty good at getting things...
Jesse: MarkApply!
Jesse: Mark - did he - apply it?
[everyone suddenly understands everything]
Jesse: That was a cl--
Jesse: That was a clever, clever thing I did.
Oh, oh yeah, that was hhhhorribly funny.
Terribly funny. Incredible.
Cry: That was great.
[laughing]
Here's uss, chustomishing!
Jesse: Ummm...
Dodger: Yes, that.
Jesse: You could be like: ...
Look at all the colors that we can do!
Jesse: ..."Hello everybody!"
Jesse: "Welcome back toooo...
Cry: All the colors of the wind?
Jesse: ...Guns of Icarus Online.
Jesse: It's a rematch against TotalBiscuit...
Jesse: ...and we're gonna battle them again.
Jesse: But first! We're gonna do some customization
of our characters and ship to make it...
Jesse ...the way we want. So this time we win."
Something like that?
That's good. We'll go with that one.
Y--that was perfect.
Dodger: We'll just use that.
Dodger: Yeah.
[everyone agrees]
I liked the whole questioning tone throughout...
...the entire story.
Dodger: Yeah, but...
Dodger: ...but I'm not quite convinced of this myself.
Dodger: But when you say it later...
Mark: We're gonna customiiiiize?
Dodger: ...you should sound convinced.
And beat 'em? I dunno.
[Trailer-guy voice] IN A WORLD...
...WHERE 4 PEOPLE GET ON
THE STEEL BUTTERFLY...
...THEY MUST FIRST FIGURE OUT...
...WHAT COLORS THEY WANT...
...FOR THEIR CHARACTEEEEERH.
That good?
Dodger: Hmmm....
Jesse: Yeah, that's great!
But we're gonna do the ship...
Jesse: ...cause our characters are already done.
Jesse: But good effort.
Jesse: Good effort.
Mark: FUCK!
GODDAMMIT!
[laughing]
I thought you're still on the character bit.
Dodger: Good job everybody!
Jesse: All right, that's it!
Jesse: We're done! We did it! YAAAAAY!
Jesse: Ok, now what?
So anyway...
...that's all the cool stuff that's coming in the future.
I'm sorry for dropping the ball on a number of videos...
...over the past week, but I promise...
...that I will get more engaged in it in the future.
Because I am more dedicated than ever.
Whenever I take a break or a vacation...
...I'm always sitting where I'm supposed to be...
...having fun, going:
"Well, this is kinda fun, but I could be home...
...making videos right now. FOR MY FANS!"
But then I decide that I'll go...
...ride a rollercoaster, of something...
...and it'll be more fun.
So, either way, thanks you guys so much.
I will hopefully get the website up...
...in about 2 or 3 weeks here.
I'm gonna really, really plow at it...
...and get it all out of the way and done...
...and ready for you guys to use as soon as possible.
Thank you guys so much for believing in me...
...and helping me with what I do.
So, sincerely, thank you all so much for watching...
...and as always...
...I will see YOU...
...in the next video.
Buh-bye!